at first glance this looks like any
other car dealership but there is one
thing that's different about the
senorita Maria in Berlin its workforce
is all women who's asking a woman says I
don't have much money owner Maria actor
says they were sitting around mulling
what they could do differently to stand
out from the crowd then she thought how
about a car dealership staffed
exclusively or mainly by women many
women avoid car showrooms for fear of
getting strange looks or asking a dumb
question so they thought they could make
things more pleasant and friendly for
women God if you're contracting Lucas
catch heaven does this hurt yeah I miss
an angle Nima on frontage road I just
bcos the senorita Maria dealership sets
itself apart from the competition once
upon a time men build cars for other men
and men bought cars for women today
things have changed this customer likes
the female friendly dealership because
it's still a very male dominated trade
cars dealerships repair shops she thinks
it's great massage princess castle this
budding saleswoman says the training
program is informative and it's nice to
work with so many women and what's
normally a male domain they have long
talks so you always know what's going on
stinka Cecilia hi then a male customer
arrives while the senorita Maria
dealership caters to the special needs
of its female clientele it's happy to
serve men as well customer service rep
Jennifer lunga welcomes Mario moolah
he's brought his car in for an
inspection and to have his infotainment
system chat
he see us I think he doesn't see this as
anything really unusual as these days a
mechanic's job is so varied and has a
lot to do with electronics in that
respect he says women are just as good
as men same applies for reception and
sales of course it's nice to be welcomed
by a smiling woman but otherwise it's
nothing special for him Nicholas paul
lozito among wouldn't talks are in Konya
abundance those filippis pizano the
garage is staffed solely by women to
technology fan sarah huebner thinks
nothing of working in a domain that was
once reserved for men she'd never led
machos put her down but so far they've
never tried these days mechanics need
brains as well as brawn as car
electronics become ever more complex
it's been at so cough technically she
became a mechanic as she used to play
with cars and Domino tiles rather than
dolls she got that from her father he
tinkered with cars in his free time and
she joined him in his hobby I tech me
such a lafond she's been out to a
difficult call them on tops off we went
home Jennifer and London brings a job
order into the repair shop all of the
employees here appreciate the direct
contact with clients
Mario Muller wants to know why parts of
his vehicles infotainment system aren't
working the mechanic tells him nothing's
broken everything's fine in this case
the problem lies elsewhere free liquid
ice is uh yeah the customer admits it's
a little embarrassing when the sales rep
suggests you might want to read the
instruction manual it's all in there but
otherwise everything's fine paying a
visit to this car dealership in garage
is a really pleasant experience one that
men too are increasingly coming to
appreciate